tell me about having Kelly Clarkson in
the room the original American Idol yeah
well not only original but just a
phenomenal singer and a phenomenal judge
she did a great job tonight were you
surprised
no I because she's super real you know
she she doesn't have two different
personalities she's just that it's just
so refreshing to be around that and see
that tell me about being in the room for
that performance she got so emotional
hmm well and I mean the song it's insane
I mean I figure you're either crying at
this performance so you need to check
your pulse is the amazing song I mean
were you and also she's very pregnant
right now were you worried at all that
she was I was that I wonder if maybe I
was - I was getting tears of falling out
I'm like am I on line or what's gonna
and no it was that but it mean it was
such it I mean separate to her
incredible gift as a singer and the song
and the performance but the humanity in
that moment was chess well you never see
that let alone on television so it was I
was so grateful to be there to witness
it